oui
[Musique]
dis moi comment reconnaît-on l'intérieur
d'une personne bonjour votre majesté ou
résident l'amour la vérité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nos pensées ou la folie
comme souvenir
de grâce souvenez vous
[Musique]
droit il
il m'a volé ma cour vous oubliez la
manière dont on salue un roi la
vengeance est à moi en fait il se passe
des choses étranges ce château il te
faut craindre la seule sauvegarde c'est
la crainte nous pouvons prendre la fuite
venez tu à monter mon fils contre moi je
pense qu ophélie est très dangereuse
il fallut mariée à un autre
ça commence maintenant
on est là
[Musique]
la vengeance la folie la perte d'un
royal
rien n'est comme il y paraît
[Musique]